CBS News legal analyst Ricky Kleeman is
with us in studio 57 and chief legal
correspondent Jan Crawford joining us
from Washington there were with us
yesterday as we watched the hearing
unfold good morning again guys when we
did have a front row seat I have to say
that's one thing I like about this job
you really do have a front-row seat to
history but let's talk about the
testimony yesterday she was 100% certain
he was 100% certain on the opposite side
who do you believe Ricky well it depends
on who you are
she was anguish she clearly has a new
she I'm gonna start with her and go get
her okay go to him
she was anguished she was passionate and
she made her heart break the Republicans
were very respectful of her even in
their comments outside of the hearing
room and she was I think for almost
everyone 100% believable then we turned
to him and frankly I did not expect him
to be able to come back with the same
kind of passion and the same kind of
anguish and he shocked me because he did
his opening statement was so painful
that for many of us we had to look away
so when you're in this balance I think
it comes to the fact of whom do you
believe it depends on what you brought
when you started to watch Jan let me ask
you how effective do you believe that
Rachel Mitchell was and asking the
questions on behalf of Republicans well
I mean I think it was kind of unclear as
as the hearings began because at some
point it seemed it was really kind of
hard to follow what was she doing with
some of the questions she was asking of
Ford and was she laying the groundwork
for something but at the end of the day
I think that Republicans have to be
pretty pleased with the decision to use
her to ask those questions because it
really diffused kind of the the tone of
the room and so by the time Cavanaugh
was testifying in the afternoon you
didn't have this heightened atmosphere
of drama and tension as much you
certainly you had it from the witnesses
but I mean what the senator is kind of
going at it you didn't
have any of that so I think that that
really for the Republicans perspective
is a decision that they're pretty happy
with Jim what do you make of the ABA
smooth I don't think that I'll have any
impact whatsoever you've got to think
about conservatives who have a
tremendous distrust for the American Bar
Association and they were shocked when
it came out and unanimously gave him his
highest rating so I think what I'm
hearing from conservatives it's morning
and Republicans is that this is pretty
much what they've expected and they're
surprised it took them this long to call
for delay ricky-ricky and Jan or our
legal dream team thank you